hey guys it is the 14th of October today
I'm just and this is gamespot news
result Bungie has come out to suit fan
concerns over destinies
microtransactions currently the only
thing that players can purchase the real
world money are a moat which have no
tangible effect on the game's content
some fans however think that this could
open doors to micro transactions that do
including drop rates for loops for
example creative director Luke Smith
responded to this on Twitter by saying
we aren't nor are we planning on selling
consumable sebastian's for drop rates
silver kingsfall beans and you raid and
silver being the game's currency that
costs you real world money while this
has been dispelled there's been no
official word from Bungie that they
won't begin selling level boosters like
the one that comes with the taken king
to instantly get a character to level 25
should that happen it wouldn't be
completely uncharted territory for
activision who also sell level boosters
in world of warcraft in other destiny
things Luke Smith has agreed with many
players that rewards for Destiny's new
nightfall strikes are in his words
underwhelming he tweeted runes a low
number of coins no reputation burst week
legendaries all feel like losing we're
gonna fix it no specifics on what form
that fix will come in as yet nice have
admitted that a forty play Walker
assault mode from star wars battlefront
is unbalanced in favor of the Imperials
as many of us found during the beta
while this may appeal to those of you
who are fans of sticking to Star Wars
Canon many players have been complaining
about their inability to win matches as
part of the rebel side one fan tweeted
that he has never won on the rebel side
during a match in the beta and queried
if he was simply not good at the game
sighs community manager matthew everett
replied no it's a balancing issue within
the beta please multiplayer designer
dennis brownville added yeah it's too
tough we'll make changes based on the
feedback and data asymmetric modes of
tricky and
risky but potentially awesome that's why
we want beta test help finally director
Guillermo del Toro has come out to say
what raw thinking when it comes to the
cancellation of silent Hills del Toro
was working on the game with hideo
kojima when konami pulled the plug del
Toro told hora site bloody disgusting
some of the stuff that we were designing
for silent Hills I've seen in games that
came after like the last of us which
makes me think we were not wrong we were
going in the right direction the thing
with Kojima and silent Hills is that I
thought we would do a really remarkable
game and really go for the jugular when
you ask about how things operate that
makes no sense at all that the game is
not happening makes no [ __ ] sense at
all let me know down in that comment
section how you feel about team balance
in Star Wars Battlefront you can add the
game slot we've got stories on
Nintendo's first smartphone and how to
get battlefield hardline for free so
does everything i have for you today as
always let me know what matter to you
and I will catch you tomorrow